[Music]
dr peterson thank you for being here
thanks very much for the invitation
so let's get into trouble with the
frivolous thought police right off of
the bat the book is subtitled an
antidote to chaos you describe order as
masculine the wise king at best the
tyrant at worst and you describe chaos
as feminine these days we're told that
gender is socially constructed a figment
of our imagination
how deeply entrenched is sex how far
back do our categories of masculine and
feminine go
well they go back as well they go back
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
years
and they do seem to form part of our
fundamental cognitive architecture
we tend to see the world in in social
cognitive categories we we tend to see
the world as if it's an animated place
and
the the
the idea that sex is a large part of
being animated is an extraordinarily
deep
biological
perceptual category
so it can't be dispensed with in in any
straightforward manner it's part of the
way that we view the world
then the idea that
that
the the way that we express ourselves
sexually say let's call that gender is
malleable is obviously true to a certain
degree because human beings are
extraordinarily malleable creatures you
can tell that just by looking at fashion
variation
but that doesn't mean that gender
differences are all socio-cultural
constructs and in fact the the evidence
that they're not i would say is crystal
clear
the the political types are about 30
years behind the social science maybe
maybe 50 years behind it that's why
they're desperately turning to
legislative means to enforce their idiot
view of humanity on the rest of the
world
that that is something i frequently
notice about politics and culture is the
pop culture and the politics they are
always lagging several decades behind so
you'll see people espousing some
relativistic or nihilistic view of the
world and you say like listen man i know
you think you're sophisticated but
you're actually several decades behind
i want to talk about a dream uh that you
write about in the book you had a dream
when writing maps of meaning your first
book that you were hanging from a
chandelier in a cathedral with tiny
little people below and you woke up in
your bed and you still saw cathedral
doors close your eyes again you're back
in the center of the cathedral
was that vision a sign from god or was
it the fever dream of an academic who's
been thinking too much and is there a
difference
well i'm not sure there's a difference i
mean it took me a long time to
understand what the dream meant but i
eventually did i mean
i knew at that point
or i had figured out as part of the
process of of interpreting that dream
let's say that cathedrals were
constructed in the shape of a cross and
so to be hanging at the center of the
cross which is essentially where the
dream put me was well obviously you know
that's something that can be read in
terms of its fundamental religious
significance but that isn't that isn't
that
that isn't the most appropriate level of
analysis i wouldn't say the reason that
the reason that cathedrals are
constructed in the shape of a cross is
because the cross is a
an x that marks the spot so to speak
it's the center place of being and we're
each at the center place of being and
that's a place of that's place of
suffering
and so
part of the christian injunction is to
voluntarily accept that and to thereby
transcend it and
the dream was pointing
to me was pointing out the inevitability
of that the fact that i was being driven
towards that conclusion you see i would
i've been spent i've been spending
years i would say by that point
meditating and thinking about the fact
of the cold war and about this terrible
ideological catastrophe that we had
placed ourselves in the midst of
um partly ideological possession driving
our proclivity to put the world at risk
and
as an alternative to that kind of a
nihilistic hopelessness that involved no
central narratives whatsoever i suppose
that would be the post-modern conundrum
and
i was trying to see if there was a
pathway between those extremes that that
that was functional and the dream was
part of that process of of realization
and
that
the alternative to ideological
possession and nihilistic hopelessness
is something like
the lifting up of individual
responsibility as the proper mode of
being and that that involves voluntary
acceptance of suffering
and you're not going to act responsibly
and forthrightly in the world if you're
bitter and resentful because of your
because of the fact that your life is
tragic and that things often go wrong so
you have to transcend that it and that
the dream was part of the process by
which i was starting to understand that
i do want to get back a little bit to
that x marks the spot later because we
see it in the christian tradition we see
traditionally the cross is uh
represented with a skull at the bottom
of it because it's adam's skull and
christ is the new atom uh i i want to
get back we'll not see the idea to well
the idea there that's an unbelievably
profound idea the idea there is that
the first man so to speak
the man who's laden with original sin
and the knowledge of death is adam of
course
and that christ what christ represents
is the antidote to what brought adam
down and so
adam was brought down by knowledge of
death and knowledge of good and evil
knowledge of mortality knowledge of
nakedness all of that was what produced
the fall so that's that's an emergence
into self-consciousness and and the and
the emergence of the tragedy of the
self-conscious world
and then christ is portrayed as an
antidote to that and the antidote is
voluntary acceptance of that burden and
simultaneously transcendent simultaneous
transcendence of it as a consequence of
the voluntary adoption and that's put
forth in the christian corpus as the
imitation of christ
so which is a theme of course that runs
through catholicism and protestantism
and orthodox christianity alike i don't
think it's something that's that's
attended to enough in the western
christian traditions which tend to
emphasize our
universal salvation through the
sacrifice of christ which is
well it has its utility in that it takes
some of the moral responsibility off
human beings but it has its price too
because it does the same thing
it it lessens the it lessens the
listens the importance of what each of
us do to some degree and the sobriety of
it
right you know there is the christ tells
us take up your cross and but he also
says my yoke is easy and my burden is
light
and it is true certain traditions fall a
little bit too much to one side or to
the other and they don't they don't hold
that tension that that you see in the in
your dream that it clearly uh pervades
the book
i i well that idea too of the burden
being light that's a very interesting
one because it's a very great paradox
but
you know one of the things that's quite
interesting about
attempting to
only say things that you believe to be
true and then also to acting
acting in a manner commensurate with
that is that it does make things lighter
because you're you're much less likely
to be burdened by your past you know
you're not guilty and afraid that the
terrible things that you've done are
going to come to light and you're not
sleeping uneasily on a
bed of nails that's your guilty
conscience and so there's a lightness
about it that
and a lightness about accepting things
even though it's a very dark act in some
sense to accept things there's a
lightness that comes along with it um
it's the lightness of being all in i
would say something like that and
the opposite of that when one doesn't
have that the culture is so burdened by
itself it begins to hate itself you
write a quote now also another problem
has arisen which was perhaps less common
in our harsher past it is easy to
believe that people are arrogant and
egotistical and always looking out for
themselves
the cynicism that makes that opinion a
universal truism is widespread and
fashionable but such an orientation to
the world is not at all characteristic
of many people they have the opposite
problem they shoulder intolerable
burdens of self-disgust self-contempt
shame and self-consciousness
why in 2018 do we so hate ourselves
well i think that that paragraph does
it does lay out a lot of it but we've
added additional sources of guilt to
that that are i think part of the modern
what would you call manifestation of the
idea that human beings have original sin
and or fallen creatures like we blame
ourselves on mass for the depredations
that the planet suffers at our hands and
let's say without any commensurate
sympathy for ourselves i mean
there are a lot of us you know
we're we're going to hit 9 billion by
midway through this century and then it
looks like things will probably um
level out but that's a lot of people and
we're we're putting a very heavy load on
on planetary resources let's say and out
competing a lot of animals and well you
know the whole environmental catastrophe
story you bloody well hear that all the
time
but you know mostly what we're trying to
do is to survive and survive with a
relative minimum of excess misery and
we're trying to do that the best way we
can see fit it's only been since the
1960s
that we've started to recognize
ourselves as a force of planetary
significance right you know 100 years
ago we believed the oceans were
inexhaustible that was a conclusion that
was that was drawn by a commission that
was set up by the british parliament and
so it's only been
not not even in my lifetime you know i'm
older than the idea that we are a
planetary shaping force but we we
carry
terrible guilt about about the price we
have to pay for existence you know and
you hear people say things like well the
planet would be better off without us
which is like an absolutely horrifying
thing to say
but
but it's uh but it i can understand why
people say it even though i think it's a
dreadful thing to say but it's never
said with any sympathy like we
we're fighting against mortality itself
as and all the suffering that goes along
with that it's not surprising that we
don't do it perfectly it's a virtually
impossible load
and so if you add that existential load
as the member of a of a species say with
with the kind of power we have to the
knowledge that each person has of their
own inadequacy and failings then you
know we carry a heavy existential burden
with something that was very well
developed by the existential
psychologist the 1950s and people feel
guilty and ashamed about about being
just about being human and then they
don't treat themselves very well and
that's not helpful it's it's not a it's
not a solution to the problem
it isn't even anti-american or
anti-western or this it is anti-human
fundamentally and you quote the the
columbine shooter in the book who wrote
nothing means anything anymore and one
aspect i really enjoy about this book is
the constant weaving together of
different disciplines of university of
philosophy and psychology everybody and
her mother is on depression drugs these
days and yet i suspect a great deal of
apparently psychological problems are
really essentially philosophical
problems this pervasive cultural
nihilism that robs people of meaning of
a sense of meaning what portion of our
social malaise do you think is
philosophical and how did we get here
oh i think it's deeper than that even it
might be theological like i think the
culture war that we're in is essentially
a theological war it's a war on it's a
war on the very idea of the transcendent
individual
and some of that some of that can be
conceptualized psychologically but
but
but that's not the deepest possible
level of conceptualization i mean our
culture is predicated on the idea that
each human being this is this this is
the source of the idea of natural right
let's say or of individual sovereignty
there's an idea that each person is uh
is touched by divinity let's say it is
made in the in an image of god that
actually means something
in the context of the story within which
it's to be interpreted so the word of
god which was active at the beginning of
time in the judeo-christian account of
creation
used truthful language to extract
habitable order from chaos and i think
that is what human beings do i don't
think we've ever formulated a more
accurate representation of the nature of
human consciousness because we confront
potential we call that the future we
confront an infinite landscape of
potential and we choose how we're going
to make it manifest itself in concrete
reality like that is really what our
consciousness seems to do and and that
brings
new being into being and our legal
systems are predicated on the idea that
that capacity should be given all due
respect right as the generator and
re-creator of culture itself and like
you can't just throw away that idea it's
the idea on our which our society rests
and the post-modern neo-marxist types
are after that idea hammer and tongs
they hate everything about it and so
that's why i think it's a theological
battle that's why darides said you know
he called western culture fellow fellow
ghost-centric fellow p-h-a-l-l-o
and he meant male-dominated and
logos-centered which is
well it's certainly logo centered is he
going to criticize that well yeah i'm
going to criticize the idea of the of
the sovereign individual and that's
certainly what the post-modern types do
didn't he didn't dare he doesn't say
it's upon them i would say
didn't he say there's nothing outside of
the text or it's all everything is
relative everything is a matter of
interpretation
yeah well he disputed whether or not he
really said that but i think of course
he would be accurate well right and i
think it's a pretty accurate summation
of the post-modern ethos they're they're
skeptical of meta-narratives of
transcendent narratives well that's all
well and good except that
like if you and i
make an agreement so that we can live
together peacefully and cooperate and
compete over the long run it's because
we've established a narrative that
transcends both our individual
identities
and if we're going to live together as a
culture that means that despite our
individual and cultural differences
let's say and let's say we can maintain
as many of them as possible we need to
subordinate ourselves to a transcendent
narrative that actually constitutes the
framework for peace and cooperation
and for and for civilized
competition there's no let's dispense
with the with the meta narrative it's
like that means let's dispense with that
which unites us well then all we have is
fragments and then we're going to fight
because human beings tend to fragment
towards their tribes and then fight
right and that's what i see happening
both on the left the left is pushing it
i would say with with with with
everything they've got and the radical
right is responding in kind it's really
not good my pillow wants to give back to
our listeners you can get great
discounts on all my pillow products if
you go to
mypillow.com right now and click on the
radio listeners specials
i love my pillow it's a great
conservative patriotic company so we all
we all kind of like them because of
their politics but i tell you they could
be run by the taliban right now and i'd
still probably buy their products
they're that good okay they're that good
the pillows the mattress toppers the
towels so much more they've also got a
buy one get one free offer on the giza
sheets these are top quality sheets
you're going to love them they have a 60
day money back guarantee with a 10 year
warranty but you're not going to need
that warranty or the money back
guarantee because you're going to love
them so much so head on over there right
now check out the buy one get one free
offer on the giza sheets use promo code
dailywire at checkout or call
800-651-1148
you'll also get deep discounts on all my
pillow products including the pillows
the slippers the my pillow mattress
topper my pillow towel sets and so much
more 1-800-6511
tell them daily wire sent you
1-800-651-1148
these deals will not last forever so
call now
i love this central theme of the book of
culture as a natural fact of the world
because in our highly scientific age
many people seem to think or take it as
a given that we just perceive the bare
world the valueless facts of the world
without any meaning and then we ascribe
later meaning to those things you write
in the book uh quote there is a little
more natural than culture
that we perceive
well
my question on this is what does that
say about how we should live
well it's one of the things it says is
that you can't
exist outside of a framework of value
it's not possible it's not technically
possible i outlined this in quite quite
a bit of detail in chapter 10 which is
called rule 10 which is called be
precise in your speech is that
the way the world manifests itself to
you is integrally tied to your value
structure and that's because to put it
very simply is that
your very vision is dependent on
an aim
like whenever you look at the world
you're aiming at something you're aiming
at something with your eyes you you
can't focus on something without aiming
at it and you won't aim at it without
valuing it so your very perceptions are
dependent on your value structure now
that doesn't mean there isn't a world it
means that it does mean that experience
is a complex interplay of your value
structure and and the unmanifest world
it's something like that and then that
begs the question which is well if you
have to have a value structure then what
should it be well and then that brings
us back to the ideas that we were
talking about earlier like you you you
should
you should value being you should take
on the responsibility of being as your
highest ethical obligation and try to
improve it try to reduce suffering try
to try to make the most out of yourself
in a way that's beneficial to you and
your family in your community you should
aim high
and
your perceptions will reconfigure
themselves around those aims and that
will
allow the world to manifest itself to
you in the most positive possible manner
or at least in the most meaningful pause
possible manner and in the absence of
that all you have is stupid suffering
that is that is the anxiety and
depression that we talked about earlier
without a point without value without a
name all you're left with is the misery
and anxiety of life that makes people
bitter
i love
the even the note to bring up the notion
of the aim because there are one can
react to this stupid suffering in a
number of ways but this is so clear you
write in it you say uh you cannot aim
yourself at anything if you are
completely undisciplined and untutored
you will not know what to target you
won't fly straight even if you do get
your aim right and and then you will
conclude there is nothing to aim for and
then you will be lost and and these days
the prevailing moral framework as i see
it is if it feels good do it
how is it the discipline and the
straight and narrow offer the best
chance for a good life and and
how is it that we have forgotten
that is the case
well the reason that discipline is
necessary is because
you're a mass of competing short-term
interests
and so the question is then well which
short-term interest should win out and
the answer to that is well none of them
they need to be organized into a
hierarchy
that makes them functional across time
and across individuals so like a
two-year-old is very likely to act out
his or her
proximal impulse but of course a
two-year-old can't survive in the world
you have to regul you have to bring your
your
primary instincts let's say
under the regulatory structure of a
higher order value system that allows
them to manifest themselves without
undue mutual sacrifice across large
spans of time in the presence of large
numbers of other people so that requires
a very sophisticated ordering it's like
we already talked about the fact that a
narrative is necessary to unite
subcultures say so that they can operate
peacefully and harmoniously within the
same space the same thing applies within
you because you're like you're an
internal coalition of warring
single-minded tribes and they have to
all be brought under the organizational
structure of long-term collective vision
let's say and in order to do that you
have to be disciplined and any
discipline
speaking you know technically speaking
is an attempt to bring all those
competing short-term impulses under a
large a larger scale and more inclusive
framework
and so
you do that and then well that's
actually what gives you freedom
being impulsive and being free aren't
the same things because if you're
impulsive you're just the slave of your
impulses right
there's no freedom in that that's that's
just
that's the same freedom so to speak
literally that a two-year-old has
because a two-year-old isn't socialized
yet
so it's not
it's a completely
it that doesn't function in this in the
sophisticated world it doesn't work
right everyone knows it we just like to
pretend sometimes we say oh that does
feel good you know now i i have one we
like to pretend all the time because
that's why we go out and drink you know
because drinking enables you to blind
yourself to the long-term consequences
of your actions and there's no doubt
that that's
very very rewarding in the short term
but it's also why you wake up the next
morning hungover and ashamed
i must tell you dr peterson we
celebrated st patrick's day and my
birthday on this saturday and i can
attest with real world experience to
your theoretical notions i have one last
question that i want to ask you you call
for people to consider meaning as the
higher good
you write consider then that the
alleviation of unnecessary pain and
suffering is a good later in the book
you call satan and our image of hell a
dreamlike fantasy later still you say
that hell is metaphysically true in the
final chapters you write a very moving
what seems to be series of prayers to
quote the source of all revelatory
thought in a discussion with god my
question
which is it i'm not asking about
metaphor or symbol and symbolized or
signifier and signified is god fact or
fantasy
maybe god's both
but if you had to pick one i don't mean
to be glad about it well no i don't i
don't think you can do that in in a
discussion like this because
you're talking about matters where the
distinction between those things
actually starts to blur
you know because there's a reality for
example there's a reality to fantasy
that we don't really understand
fantasy is how new things come into
being and fantasy has a structure it has
this archetypal structure
and so
i mean
let's see if i can come up with a
bitters
i i can't i can't come up with an answer
to that that's so blunt because look one
of the things i mentioned while we were
having this discussion was that our
legal system is predicated on the idea
that each individual is made in the
image of god and that there's actually a
reason for that that it's tied into the
judeo-christian narrative and the
narrative suggests that the way that you
bring habitable order the habitable
order that is good into being so that's
what happens in genesis at the beginning
of of time is by using truthful speech
and that there's something divine about
that it's like as far as i'm concerned
that's a fantasy but it's also factually
true it's a place where the metaphor and
the literal unite but is there a
distinction to be made here between
uh metaphor metaphysical reality and
some sort of fantasy you know uh in the
sense that a unicorn would be a fantasy
i don't think a unicorn is has
metaphorical
metaphorical truth and metaphysical
reality but uh
although i think there are some forms of
fantasy that don't have their literal
counterpart let's say sure they don't
have their real counterpart but there
are some places where fantasy and
reality meet
and we don't understand those places
very well
i don't understand them very well i
think part of the reason that i have a
hard time answering questions like that
is because they transcend the limits of
my knowledge i actually don't know how
to answer the question like
i see because
it is the case as far as i can tell that
the central presumption of our
functional legal system is that each
person has within them a spark of
divinity and that that spark of divinity
manifests itself in the bringing into
being of the present from the potential
of the future i think that's all true is
that a fact like is is that the sort of
truth that we would call a fact i think
it isn't this well possibly but it's
it's not it's not the sort of fact that
you discover
that it doesn't it doesn't sit easily in
the category of facts that scientists
have produced right it's more like an
inference so let's say you observe a
bunch of people acting a particular way
and then you say well here's the rule
that describes their action
you say well does that does that rule
represent what does that rule represent
does that represent a reality well it
represents a reality of sorts but it
isn't the same sort of reality that's
represented by a pure scientific
discovery they're not in the same
category so i'm not exactly sure what
i'm look if here again here's the
observation
if people treat one another as if
they're touched by divinity
their personal lives improve their
familial lives improves their social
structures stabilize they produce
functional political systems and and
productive economies does that make
that proposition true
well possibly but it doesn't make the
proposition a fact in the same way that
scientific investigation makes a
scientific fact of course
i i asked the question and i replicate
it i asked the question in this way
because i think you write with
heartbreaking beauty about christianity
about the the metaphysical logos that is
made flesh and dwells among us and
watching you write about this in the
book is hugely edifying so i reckon we
talk about theological issues a lot on
the show i highly recommend that
everybody goes out and reads uh 12 rules
for life and also i i pressed the
question that way because my bishop
promised me a toaster if i could baptize
you but that we might have to save that
for another program dr peterson thank
you so much for being here it has been a
wonderful conversation i will finally
allow you to go on and move on with i'm
sure you're very busy rest of your day
well thank you very much for the
interview and for the conversation
[Music]
[Music]
you